they have been extremely impressive now  they're going for the endzone here back  to Victor  and they'll come in a touchdown Benjamin  vector is fifth of the season this is  just a jump ball to bend Victor will  portray Avery and that left foot you can  see his toe in bounds when you dive into  the stats the most impressive thing  about this Ohio State offense and the  individuals like JK Dobbins is that  imagine what their statistics would look  like if they were playing for quarters  going deep here fields he wants a lot  back he's gay  Chris Allah they all the way down to the  10-yard line  just crazy good plus 21 so far today  looking for more hit the tiny and 13  times coming into today but there is one  of the tight ends Luke Farrell with his  third catch of the season and fields as  a nice stop put the ball right on the  money but he's walking Rutgers rushes  for fields going deep did he catch that  flag and yes he did catch it  Chris Olave with a flag to booth